les amis brice henry est vous qui nous
regardent et bien évidemment est ce que
vous seriez prêt c'est une question
presque philosophique est ce que vous
seriez prêt à pardonner une infidélité
ah oui et bien ça commence souvent par
aller dans ça commence aujourd'hui sur
france 2 on a fait la connaissance de
julien alors julien est absolument
délicieux et charmant comme garçon et
c'est un jeune homme qui a su surmonter
l'adultère de son épouse disait juste
j'aimerais pas qui quand on est amoureux
tous les deux parce que je gino femmes
toi aussi tu as ton mari je le
comprenais mais je rigolais parce qu'en
fait plus le temps passait et plus moi
j'étais en train de tomber amoureuse de
lui on m'a dit écoute je viens j'ai
l'âge est plus trop quoi faire il m'a
proposé de vivre chez lui vous l'avez
laissée aller vivre avec semble tout à
fait et vous pendant ce temps là vous
êtes raccrocher au fait qu'elle allait
revenir vous l'aimiez toujours rien on
avait une activité en commun on faisait
de danse tous les mardis donc le mardi
bg jallet la chercher chez ce type là
que je vais proposer dès la première
fois une focale est parti donc de dormir
à la maison donc là c'était elle a
prétexté que elle dormait chez sa mère
où en cachette
oui vous avez fait votre mari est devenu
votre amant oui à la situation assez
ubuesque a quand même ville il est très
gentil 33 % des femmes déclarent avoir
déjà été infidèles je vous regarde la
fête voir 49 % des hommes à était déjà
un fidèle dont il ya des locales à 2
voilà et 4% des femmes actuellement en
couple actuellement en couple à magalas
à avoir un amant 4% des femmes
voilà alors les raisons qui pousseraient
les femmes à l'infidélité d'abord
l'attirance physique pu les sentiments
pour la personne et enfin le manque
d'attention du conjoint donc c'était la
foire de l'autre que vous en pensez
caroline a su vous seriez prête vous à
pardonner une éventuelle infidélité moi
j'écoute les contrats les rênes
je peux en tout cas ni d'un contrat il
me semble que je serai prête à pardonner
l'infidélité dans le couple ah bon je
pense je pense que ce serait dans ma
nature de comprendre que à un moment
donné effectivement l'autre va voir
ailleurs peut-être aussi parce que moi
j'ai laissé faire j'ai autorisé j'ai
fermé les yeux j'ai pas vu sur du coup
à présent je suis vraiment capable de
reconnaître que c'est un peu 50 50
il ya celui qui fait celui qui va et
puis diallo qui reste et qui croient que
les sms que la confiance avait pas
inhaler elle n'est pas altérée
définitivement silence mais bon ça à ça
ajoute du piment après on voit là on
essaye on essaye de recoller les
morceaux qu est-ce qui c'est de repartir
sur de bonnes bases et terra mais
attention parce que là le sujet c'était
aussi l'amour au bureau attention aux
gens qui travaillent le bureau abonde un
endroit ex 2 tentation de tentations
extrême à la houn et ces gens là la
prendre pour les gens elle pète un lieu
qui est difficile on a besoin de tisser
des liens avec les collègues
il ya soixante pour cent des gens qui
fantasme sur leurs collègues amis et
anita dire que vous convoitez cder quand
vous tisser des liens vous allez faire
la bagatelle
bon d'accord très bon local très
difficile et elle s'est passé c'est bien
possible bien sûr pour décompresser
voilà bien évidemment à will allen avec
caroline tu verras qu'à un moment donné
ton piment il va te donner des
hémorroïdes parce que je suis désolé
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne non
quoi cette image parce que ça va être un
moment donné la confiance et n'existe
plus d'ailleurs l'article
alors donc vous vous dites et là je ne
parle jamais mais jamais et d'ailleurs
l'article 212 du code civil indique que
les époux se doivent mutuellement
fidélité donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle en plus de divorce et j'aurais
demandé des dommages et intérêts à bath
la santé la caverne en première instance
qui réagit on dit la conversation quand
même sens bien bien sûr dans vos
vêtements de rijeka de carrément de
l'argent oui exactement
et pardonnez moi alors je vais je posais
une question qui me semble quand même
importante est ce que là ce n'est pas
l'amour propre qui passe à sézanne amour
tout court
non vous êtes blessé dans votre orgueil
deux petits mâles et gueuler vous dit
après tout ça je l'aimais tant pis je ne
veux pas lui pardonne mais peut-être que
vous avez raison mais après voir son
visage en disant eh bien dans quelqu'un
d'autre est allé dessus et ce n'est pas
de ça oui ça m'embête ça m'embête je
suis désolé monde a bien mais tu réagis
comme un élève
voilà comme un bébé je suis désolé si la
personne revient mais pour les bonnes
raisons
pas parce que c'est fait plaquer ou quoi
que ce soit mais qu'elle a eu une
révélation
oui moi clairement je peux je leur
adresse et que ça donne 10
qu'effectivement ça a permis d'aller
dire presque d'euros exactement couple
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte que la
personne aimée était celle que vraiment
vaisselle a vraiment content aussi que
oui un couple s'est pas seulement vivre
ensemble et être ensemble et faire la
bagatelle de temps en temps c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut travailler au
quotidien
c'est éviter la routine s'est appréciée
aussi la routine qui est quand même
relativement agréable
on va poser la question évidemment à
celui dont on attend tous la réponse il
un événement plus drôle c'est qu'il est
particulièrement à l'aise sur ce genre
de sujet le docteur jimmy mohamed qu'en
pensez-vous de la fidélité est ce que
vous seriez prêt à pardonner une
éventuelle incartades de madame je
répondrais si vous répondez à la
question et vous madame benhabib
seriez vous prête je pense alors
pourrait tout à fait honnête que j'ai
accompagné moi je crois qu'elle a dit
oui à la mairie
effectivement partie moment où on a un
petit vécu on n'a pas quinze ans
effectivement on peut imaginer que
l'autre a eu un instant j'ai un
acouphène qui se met en place dès lors
que l'autre peut avoir fait un petit pas
de côté et essayer de comprendre pour
reconstruire quelque chose
éventuellement parce que l'amour propre
encore une fois c'est pas l'amour et
donc que j'ai été blessé dans mon
orgueil voyez moi je pense que ceux qui
sont prêts à pardonner sont ceux qui ont
fauté
je pense que très sincèrement on peut
savoir jamais assez non car moi je pense
que c'est non à montbard donnerait
jamais je vous le dis a donc laissé un
message à madame la vengeance mais c'est
impossible
je pense que la confiance vous avez des
enfants ensemble pour construire quelque
chose ya eu un petit écart n'y a pas des
cas pas de petit écart c'est quoi ce
petit match et c'est dire quoi car c'est
quoi un petit éclat un petit écart est
un v6 un petit
[Rires]
voilà c'est un pas de claquettes et à
c'est un petit pas de côté parce que
peut-être que on peut aussi se remettre
en cause on peut aussi se dire que vous
n'avez pas été à la hauteur de ce
qu'attendent et dans ces cas-là chemin
de fer que les gens se séparent dise les
choses plutôt que d'aller voir ailleurs
je pense que l'adultère ruine à challans
c'est ma vision peut-être rétrograde et
je peux le comprendre mais ce serait
impardonnable par donald et rigolo mais
ce qu'est la rédac on a fait ce petit
jeu du est-ce que tu pardonneras ou pas
tous les mecs ont dit non toutes les
nanas ont dit oui
voilà une information pardonner une
infidélité on vous a posé la question
pourriez le faire vous avez déjà
pardonné ou bien jamais de la vie et
vous nous avez dit que vous pourriez
faire à 28% que vous avez déjà pardonné
à 15 % ce qui est beaucoup ce qu'ils
n'ont jamais de la vie à 57% donc la
moitié des duos et les filles ont
répondu très bien